diminuerait le tout nouveau champion du
monde des chats il vient de subir sa
première défaite avec sa couronne
seulement en 10 jours après son sacre et
cocorico c'est un tricolore qui le lui a
infligé elle est résa firuga le prodige
de 18 ans effectué son grand retour à la
compétition après 8 mois d'absence et
malgré sa passion dévorante pour la mode
il a démontré encore capable de mouiller
la chemise puis c'est imposé à l'issue
d'un gros combat de 53 coups il a aussi
prouvé sa capacité à tailler des
costards puisque après sa victoire il a
déclaré que Digne-les-Bains était un
champion du monde plus facile que Magnus
Carlsen alors cette victoire offrant
plus en bonus à les raisins à la place
de numéro de mondial avec 2788 hello
soit deux points de plus que nepo battu
le même jour par mvl petit clin d'oeil
tricolore au passage alors elle est résa
partira-t-il à rattraper car scène 2853
qui caracole toujours en tête le
Norvégien affirmant en tout cas qu'il
est pour lui largement le joueur le plus
talentueux la nouvelle génération